methane bubbling up from the Nord stream
pipelines in the Baltic Sea after two
explosions were recorded in the area
Monday we basically know what a blast of
a hundred kilo mine looks like uh so
it's very clear this is not an
earthquake earthquakes and blasts are
quite different both nordstring
pipelines are designed to send natural
gas directly from Russia to Germany one
has controversially been shut down since
August Germany suspended certification
on Nordstrom 2 after Russia's February
invasion of Ukraine one of the leagues
happened close to the brand new Baltic
pipeline between Norway and Poland
leaders at that pipeline's opening
didn't explicitly blame Russia but the
Kremlin has faced accusations it has
weaponized energy during the war by
throttling Supply to Europe I think
there's basically only one actor right
now that actually benefits from more
uncertainty and that is Russia Russia
that is using gas exactly as a pressure
point
in South and Eastern Ukraine for
so-called referendums wrap up Russian
installed authorities say preliminary
results show more than 97 percent are in
favor of joining Russia the votes
labeled illegal and a sham by Kiev and
the West British intelligence says
Vladimir Putin could announce the
annexation of the regions this week
these are some of Russia's newly
mobilized reservists who could be
fighting to keep that land as even
Moscow admits to errors in its
recruitment those who fear the draft
continue to flee in their thousands
lines at the Georgian border Tuesday
snaking back 16 kilometers Redmond
Shannon Global News London